update on the Dylan Dennis story um so
Dylan danis leaks a video of Logan
Paul's girlfriend asking for someone to
recommend her a big fat
ah that can destroy her body let's pull
up the clip
by the way I'm very proud of myself this
is the longest I've ever gone without
sex since I started
obviously it's driving me crazy
I am struggling
I mean penis inside of me
ASAP
like all I want is like a big fat
sausage just
destroying my body
so if any of you guys know a good deck
that doesn't have STDs on it I'll take
it right here I can't believe she posted
all this voluntarily that's a funny
thing about us ladies it's like we'll do
anything for attention attention really
is our currency so you might look at
this stuff and think why would why would
anyone post that well
that's just that's just how we are and I
I see this stuff I'm not surprised you
know but you know we are how we are
um
now Logan Paul has now said that this
has not affected his relationship with
her and it's only made it stronger
here's the clip and Nina's she's a
angel bro I don't feel like
going online she's like the nicest
person I think for him he was hoping he
would try to break you guys but if
anything's probably made you guys
stronger so much stronger so it's like
yeah I love this girl so much
yeah nothing will get between us not
some fake lying Internet troll
whose life has devolved to pretending to
be a fighter
just want to know how he rationalizes
all of this you know maybe you could say
she had a past she learned from it okay
you know I I could maybe understand that
thought process but the idea that this
chick's going online and talking like
these are all long-term relationships I
don't really buy
um
but you know I don't know her personally
I'd love to I'd love to get her on a
show and ask her like what her
interpretation of all of this is you
know I feel like if everybody's talking
about her they should at least give her
the chance to
go through explain them I I don't know
but this is a lot guys
um we still haven't seen the video that
will quote unquote end their marriage I
guess we'll see at the fight but yeah
guys pick pick your chick carefully this
is why I say go for the 20 year old
chicks that don't have a mountain of
evidence against against them on
Instagram you know yeah go for the 20
year olds